look some things may be true even if
donald trump
said them only now are we allowed to
mention that perhaps this lab leak
started in wuhan and was covered up by
the chinese government because trump's
gone now
if you think that trump can't ride that
hobby horse back to the white house
i eat no for breakfast
over the weekend kamala harris did an
interview with mika brzezinski on msnbc
and
and the the msnbc crew is
just i mean when we talk about in the
tank they are in the tank i mean let me
begin with this
joe scarborough says that joe biden is
returning the united states to normalcy
which is just
insane i'm sorry there is no way that
joe biden has done anything to return
america to normalcy
if things if anything things have gotten
even more wild in terms of policy
the thing about donald trump is that his
policies were actually relatively normal
he himself in terms of personal behavior
not super normal his policies
pretty normal the biden administration
joe biden is wandering about
wandering into household objects and
knocking them over
he's chasing his dog and breaking his
foot by trying to grab his tail or
something
but he's pushing radical policy joe
scarborough is in favor of the radical
policy so long as it comes along with
this
veneer of normalcy of grandpa joe
wandering around shouting at the clouds
it's not good for this country to be
talking about politics 24 hours say
that's not who we are
fighting about well or even talking
about politics obsessing about politics
people looking at msnbc or fox
24 hours a day or cnn 24 hours a day
i feel like you like you know then to
ferris bueller what are you still doing
go out like do something get out you
know
and donald trump had people talking
about donald trump including us 24 hours
a day
i think this return to normalcy it
cannot be overstated
there is no return to normalcy that's
the point there's no return to normalcy
but
joe biden is an effective face for a la
for for the the false return to normalcy
because the minute he is gone and tamil
harris is president all of this bursts
right back out into the open because she
is just terrible at this here she was
with mika now it is she she's been using
this online
and it is an obnoxious line i eat no for
breakfast i don't even know what that
means
i eat no for breakfast okay but here she
was she was
she was trotting out the the feminist
schtick i am woman
hear me roar or some such and she says
this line again to mika brzezinski
and then she laughs hysterically at her
own joke i mean
oh my god democrats are so lucky that
joe biden is president that she is not
my goodness
i eat no for breakfast she waits for the
laugh
so have i been told many times during my
career
things from oh you're too young it's not
your turn
they're not ready for you um
know one like you has done it before
i've heard all of those things many
times over the course of my career but i
didn't listen
and i would encourage anyone who's been
told that
whatever their gender to not listen
because again
don't be encumbered by the inability of
others to see the potential
of who you are i eat no for breakfast
i didn't listen this sounds very male
and successful
you'll recall this is not the first time
she's used this line she used it with
jane paulie with cbs this morning
uh this is a couple of months ago the
media my goodness
i you can't stop trying to make fetch a
thing stop trying to make camel hairs a
thing she's not a thing
okay no one is interested in camel
hair's presidency the only reason she
was picked is because joe biden felt
that in order to shore up the black vote
he needed a black vp candidate he did
not hide the ball on this he said it
quite openly
and so now you're stuck with this i mean
they they they're gonna have to
it's gonna be like el sid they're gonna
staple joe biden to a horse and ride his
corpse around to prevent kamala harris
from becoming president she's just this
bad at this
i was raised to understand many people
will tell you
it is impossible but don't listen i
mentor a lot of people and i tell them
that there will be people who will say
it's not your turn it's not your time no
one like you has done it
and i'll tell them and don't you listen
and then i will go on to tell them i eat
no for
breakfast oh
no and she's laughing at her own joke
and jane paulie is going
oh okay you're not going to make common
harrison things they're deeply
reliant on this old codger joe biden
right we all know this
and here is the thing the more the media
do this stuff the more
the media refuse to cover the issues
that are actually at play the more they
just repeat the narratives that are
pushed by democrats
the more they are opening the door for
wait for it wait for it donald trump
okay i know i haven't mentioned trump's
name for a while you know why because he
hasn't been relevant since he left the
presidency
but there is very little doubt at this
point that there is a very good chat
that joe that donald trump runs for the
presidency again
and the case that he is going to make is
not going to be a case
based on the rigging of the vote in
2020. the case he's going to be banking
is that the entire media are a
propaganda outlet
for the democratic party and they've
been covering for radical policy and you
have been paying the price and honestly
he's going to have a pretty good case
he's going to say that animus for him
meshed with animals for the american
people that the media
cared less about the american people
suffering they cared less about the
truth than they did
about going after donald trump and he
has plenty of grounds to do that
between the the democratic party and the
media combining
to push a radical racial agenda that
does not comport with reality
blowing up stories that are non-stories
into major national stories in order to
press forward the narrative that america
requires deep systemic
change or whether it is the media
actively covering up
the malfeasance of china in the
in the spread of coronavirus trump is
going to say listen
they hated this was his case before and
it's twice as good now
he's gonna say they hated me not because
they hated me but because they hated you
or at the very least they hated me so
much that they didn't care about you
and you paid the price the media for a
year
covered up the fact that there is a very
good shot that coronavirus
leaked from a wuhan lab i mean
absolutely covered up social media would
ban you
and suspend you if you so much as
suggested
that this lab leak theory was rhea was
reality
and now the media are admitting it now
that trump is gone they're admitting it
so what changed the answer is nothing
trump is gone so now they can admit the
agenda
here is jonathan carl on abc news
admitting as much he says yeah you know
what
probably we shouldn't have ignored that
because some things might have been true
even if trump said them but here's the
point
they did not give a damn about the truth
they only cared about how much they
hated trump and now the biden's in there
they still don't care about the truth
all they care about is covering their
ass so now they can come out the other
side and say well at least we were
honest when the time came we were honest
yeah bull crap
yes i think a lot of people have egg on
their face this was an idea
uh that was first put forward by mike
pompeo secretary of state
donald trump and look some things
may be true even if donald trump said
them
and there was because trump was saying
so much else that was just
out of control and because he was uh you
know making a
a a frankly racist appeal talking about
kung flu
and and the china virus his notion that
put forward that this may have or he
said flatly that this this came from
that lab
was widely dismissed but actually
there's some real reason
we don't know by the way we still don't
know i mean notice all the hedging there
even now members of the media can't just
say it was a reasonable theory
it's all about trump why is it all about
trump because it was never about the
truth
it was always about oppositional
politics here's the new york times david
leonhardt saying the same thing we never
should have killed the lab league theory
yeah you shouldn't have
that's correct but because tom cotton
said it you decided to kill the lab
league theory because all you care about
is whatever the democratic agenda is
today that's it
i think people made this mistake i think
a lot of people on the political left
and a lot of people in the media made
this mistake they said wow if tom cotton
is saying something it can't be true or
they assumed that
and that's not right tom cotton does
deal in misinformation about things like
election fraud he said some things that
are just wrong
but that doesn't mean that everything he
says is wrong and it seems like
a lot of people including a lot of
people in the media leaped to dismiss
the lab
league theory because of where it was
coming from and the reality is
we don't yet know how kovid started yeah
no bleep and it's not just that
okay here's the headline from the new
york times july 29 2020
from nicholas kristof the opinion
columnist help me find trump's
anarchists in portland
the president has his politically driven
narrative and then there's reality
help me find the anarchists right this
was the line i remember
there were journalists who literally
went to portland and they sat in the
park and they're like i don't see any
anarchists here
i don't see anything bad happening here
and because trump was focusing in on the
fact that black lives matter was
involved in violence
and because he was focusing in on the
fact that black lives matter leadership
was in fact anti-semitic and he was
focusing in on the fact they were
marxist
and he was focusing in on the fact that
the the anarchists in portland were in
fact committing acts of anarchy the
entire media decided not to cover it and
only now are they coming out and they're
like oh you know what i guess probably
we should cover it now
article today washington post anarchists
and an increase in violent crime
hijacked portland social justice
movement quote the church on the edge of
the city was built to hold thousands
and on this drizzly day the pews of mana
house were filled with hundreds of
mourners
scattered throughout the broad high
ceiling chamber to comply with pandemic
rules
nearly all of them were black they had
gathered to memorialize
jalen joachim 33 whose body lay in a
clear casket at the front of the stage
the wounds on his face had been brushed
over a blue suit and white open collar
shirt hid the rest of his scars from the
daylight shots that killed him in a
pizza restaurant parking lot this month
portland is a white city overwhelmingly
so african americans account for just
six percent of the population
but it is black people such as joachim
an aspiring union electrician who are
dying at near historic rates
and filling churches with grief on may
12th yocum a father of two young boys
became the city's 30th homicide victim
this year that is five
times the number recorded during the
same period in 2020 a frightening pace
that could see more slangs here by the
end of the year than in the past four
decades after months of social justice
activism
that made portland a vivid sometimes
violent focal point for a nation
debating the same
issues around police accountability and
reform the movement here has splintered
into bickering groups
at odds over tactics goals and an
overall direction for how to make the
city safer with the police force still
at the debate's bitter center
the sharpening conflict between rising
violent crime and efforts to reduce the
size of police departments has played
out
across the american west throughout this
pandemic year now cities such as
portland
have retrenched so of oakland berkeley
la and several other
influential cities on the issue the
nightly confrontations with police and
federal agents deployed here by
president donald trump have been
replaced by a kind of generational
hopelessness
a tenuous sense of security across an
under-policed city
and returned to an old-school style of
gun violence reminiscent of a
tit-for-tat cycle of deadly reprisals
almost always
among young men of color oh weird but
you didn't report on this
at all for a year because to report on
it would have been to acknowledge that
trump was right
okay the same thing is happening with
regard to blm there's an entire article
in the new york times today
about how the support for black lives
matter has dropped precipitously
who do they blame well they decline
first of all
views of blm drops across every single
racial group in america
why because it turns out the blm
protests
all too often turn into riots okay but
the times instead blames the gop the
article in the new york times by
jennifer trudy and hakeem jefferson they
say the precipitous decline in support
mirrors the increased politicization of
the issue by elites in the days and
weeks following floyd's death republican
politicians quickly turned attention
away from the actions of a murderous
police officer to those individuals
protesting the injustice
or um no actually blm riders injured
police officers
in 72 percent of cities that held blm
protests across the us and canada
according to the major cities chiefs
association the property damage cost up
to two billion
dollars and the riots left at least 25
people dead including retired policeman
david dorn maybe that had something to
do
with the drop in popularity as the daily
wire points out but no according to the
media only now are we allowed to mention
that blm is not all that popular only
now are we allowed to mention that
antifa is in fact a violent group only
now are we allowed to mention that there
was chaos
in portland and only now are we allowed
to mention that perhaps this lab leak
started in wuhan and was covered up by
the chinese government because trump's
gone now
if you think that trump can't ride that
hobby horse back to the white house
let me suggest that you've got this
sucker all wrong
and that when you spend years covering
for the democratic agenda
by just referring to it as sort of the
new normal
or return to normalcy you have made a
category error
joe biden was elected by the american
people in order to restore a sense of
normalcy
he was not elected in order to
effectuate radical change and yet
he took that as a mandate to effectuate
radical change increasing the budget by
a full 50 percent blowing out the
spending
to to levels we have not seen since
world war
ii he has pushed a racially polarizing
brand of politics that has been unseen
in the country
seriously for decades and the media have
covered for all of that
there is a burgeoning backlash and it is
going to hurt the democrats it is coming
for them and it should come for them
because what they've done here is
incredibly incredibly ugly
they've castigated the systems of the
united states as racist without
reference
to what in the systems is actually
racist they've castigated americans as
racist
they've made up stories about americans
being racist without actually
making sure that there's any underlying
fact to it
and when the the image that that is
being pushed by the media is so
disconnected from the actual reality
all on the basis of we have to make hay
while the sun shines all on the basis of
we have to prop this old coot up until
he can get done what he needs to get
done
and waiting in the wings is kamala
harris i gotta say i am not optimistic
for the future
of the democratic party here over the
course of the next couple of years and
neither should they be
which might be the reason why they're
pushing so hard so fast right now but
the backlash is coming
and it is well deserved did you know
that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science